Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier, and welcome to Four Last Things.
Now this game is a point-and-click adventure game that features some Monty Python...
art, oh...
beautiful Renaissance paintings ahh,
culture, art
The game of life being played out in front of us, such a beautiful experience,
that, uh
I'm liking it less. I'm liking it a lot less. You know I'm liking it. I like it not...oh
Hello, hi uh? Oh we got?
Oh, no. What are you doing to that Apple over there(dafuq)? Hi okay?
God(?):
all you need to do is avoid this forbidden fruit
Eve: Don't listen to him eat the apples
Oh okaaay? Oh...
God(?): Don't you dare eat those apples...
God? Uh God?
Adam:  Look at you that's our Lord God, Almighty the eternal omnipotent creator of everything
He's slightly less inspiring and majestic than I'd anticipated
Okay
Adam: Violence is not the answer!
Okay, all right, I think I'm gonna eat one of the forbidden fruits
I don't think I'm going to eat any of the forbidden fruits. I think I'm gonna eat one! Uh God? Hey God
Hey listen, buddy God God. I'm gonna eat one of the forbidden fruits
Don't know how to tell you this
But I just feel like it's in my destiny
God: Do not or else you shall be banished from this earthly paradise!
Eve?
God: If you thoughts apples you'll feel the wrath of God (that's me)!
Eve: The only way to stop this insane music eat the flipping apples!
hey Eve, clam down-
*Mark losing his apples while reading this* God: I will smite the crap out of you if you tough those apples! >8C
Even the creepy serpent child thinks you should eat one all right well lobby freakin da let me ponder
My choices. I shall look on the horizon and ponder in infinity what I shall do
Eve: Stop pretending you have options here. Hey Eve. That's Eve her face her hands are sticky with dried in apple juice and she smells fantastic
alright
Violence is not the answer. I think I'm gonna eat one of the forbidden fruits
excellent all right
Hmm, let me look at these wait hand hello. Hi this creepy servant child seems pretty keen on feeding me these apples
I'd rather take one of the fresh ones off the tree. I'm not gonna snaffle the Apple straight
Why don't you snaffle the Apple that's the forbidden fruit of the tree of the knowledge of good and evil looks deliciously, right?
My controller vibrated, why are you okay?
Hello
What's happening? I don't know where I am hello. Hi. How's it going? Okay alright?
This is beautiful
What's happening? Oh? Hi? Okay? Excuse me while I cut in line don't mind me hi?
Help, please help
Okay, I have sinned. I have done the most terrible things. I must give confession from my vile deeds immediately
What sins have you committed old man all of?
Wonderful terrific all seven marvelous and in which of the parish boroughs which sins committed it mainly
Nuremberg in Lubec, but I've committed lust in almost every harbour town south of Oslo ah
Oh dear, I see I'm afraid Nuremberg in Lubec don't fall within our jurisdiction
We can't take confession for sins committed in another parish why on earth not
Severely lust is lust wherever it is committed
Yes, we are all capable of forgiving you, but it's against the rules as you can see from the cue
This is a very busy church. We have to stick to the rules
So what am I to you?
( I'm gay )
We could tell him about the loophole no no no we can't tell him about the loophole, what's the loophole ah
Well, yes as we mentioned
We can absolve you of any sin
But we can't let you confess sins committed outside the parish borders if however you were to commit each sin again
within the parish borders
Then we could absolve you of everything you can't possibly expect me to commit every file deed again
No, no not every deed every sin a confession of lust covers all lustful acts
Commit each of the seven sins in this parish and your absolution will be absolute. Okay. I think I can imagine okay
All right, I think I understand how this games gonna go off. You pop all right happy sinning. Oh
Oh
All right
Try not to murder anyone don't freak out okay, all right. Hello. Hi
Innocent-looking young lady. That's one tight corset
okay, I
Would never strike a lady my staff violence. What sins are you seeking forgiveness for wrath?
I slit my father's throat for using a rude word. What was the word? I shall entropies it
Okay harmless simpleton
What a friendly looking oaf? What sins are you seeking forgiveness for gluttony? Yum? Yum yum okay?
What sins?
Pride I committed the great valorous deed of murdering a thousand innocent men in a single battle, which was great of course
But then I made the mistake of bragging about it in a brothel the following evening
They ratted meat into the local clergyman before I'd even unbuckled my codpiece
Let's see what sins greed as you can see I enjoy the finer things in life and lots of them all right
What sins she is a virtuous angel? She is here only to support my quest for absolution I?
fornicated with the stableboy
Alrighty, then she's a hottie. She's a hottie hottie
Sorry, I thought it would be fun. It wasn't I'm sorry
Okay, hello. They look. Happy enough sure okay
What sins my wife is guilty of sloth?
She spends her days in bed reading romantic. Novellas eating the food. I earned for our family
She refused even to trouble her legs and making way to this church
and you I've committed Envy by wishing I too could afford such a lifestyle ah
- beautiful organist performing a slightly clunky rendition of Lois Nicole's clamber. Oh, it's sweet that you share home
Okay, all right
Good job Bravo, all right. Okay. I'm out of here. Goodbye All Right. See ya, Oh
Who's uh who's here hello, hi how are you hi hello he seems pretty engrossed in whatever he's writing, okay?
Can I slap him this poor sap must have suffered enough torment in his time?
Okay, hello. Hello. What are you writing about?
I'm writing a poem about inspiring beauty of God's green earth
Okay, will you write a poem for me? I don't take commissions. I write because my soul requires it of me
I need to write as other men need to eat and have write only of the things that inspire me to do so if you
Show me something that inspires me to write a poem then I shall write a poem for your coins. I will do no such thing
Okay, all right
Stuck up your own ass a bit, but that's all right. What inspires you I am inspired by God's most beautiful creations
Especially the pretty ladies my finest works or poems about love
All right off you pop then hello. Hi old man with pig hello
I have no wish to talk to you boy fair enough
See you around the bed, buddy all right. Hey, okay, that's
That's bizarre all right, okay?
It's a bunch of yokels having a singsong and a floating egg. All right. We're gonna pretend. That's normal all right now
I'm gonna take my LSD and carry on my way. Can I touch him wait?
Bravo Bravo, okay, all right
Okay, that's all there is to that then what is happening here. Hello
All right, creepy weirdos a surgeon wearing a funnel hat on a fat, man receiving you on earth at the thighs brain surgery
Lady with a book on her head
Standard stuff okay, alrighty then I don't I don't even want to know what that's all about alright. Hello. Hi
Were you guys?
We're the obligatory Kickstarter backers
What's Kickstarter
It's a crowdfunding platform used to God by God to help fund the creation of this world
I'm pretty sure that's blasphemy alright. What are you doing here? We're just chillin doing fun operations ruining the artistic integrity of the game
Is getting dangerously meta I'm out here alright wait can I get a speaking part too geez what a bunch of shameless attention seeker?
He's better just lying around in the mud hello hello, they're fine for now huh, what are you doing down there?
We've eaten our fill and drank our wine skins dry and now we are simply resting friend
Don't you have work to do. We're all landowners not workers of the land our time is mainly spent in leisure
Ok alright then
Can I join you?
Between us we own many acres of land but none of us hold claim the over that spot by the tree oh
All right, I guess this is how it's gonna be
I'm Audi see ya move go over here. Now. Okay, maybe. I'm not oh yes. I am excuse me what about this lady
Churning butter and a giant butter churning well hello
Okay, fine. See ya. I'm gonna go commit some lust Oh
I walked into the weird part of town peep here huh, I'll peep okay. I'll beep oh hey
a beautiful woman reclining on a bed of plump white pillows and lady how you doing
My name is markiplier. I'm a
Pretty big deal in YouTube. I've got a lot of subscribers
How you doing? She's stunning? She's magnificent? She's surprisingly clean hello
There young lady
All right get out of here you dirty dog. I am a man sir, yeah
All right, well, then it says P pair a statue of a merry peasant is it
is
That is that the married was that the married?
This guy or
All right hello some strange-looking horn players Tooting at a fairly somber rendition of Giovanni kava-kava
Chios Khan's an alle forest
Hello this guy this guy I
Don't want to put him off his rhythm
You go girl man with pipe
Okay, man smoking a pipe. I think if you touch me. I'll twist your thumbs off. Oh
Hey, buddy, they're easy hello, what do you want um smoking or eating pours - a straw?
Smoking can I have a puff get your own you dang codger
Smoking is bad for your health just want to be that guy. Oh, he's wise mouthing strangers. Okay, all right this was an
enlightening conversation I
See yeah, slightly old looking vegetables, mmm. That's a lot of slightly old looking produce
Can I pill for some hey? You can't just pilfer my pills like that
Well piss off wench off
I'm terribly sorry, but I'm starving in penniless. I have no choice
Okay, okay, you can have some just this once. Thank you I
Got some slightly old looking vegetables. Hello excuse me. Yes, can you spare me something to drink?
Not if he ain't got coins, can you spare me something to sneeze him -?
Not if you ain't got coins
eat
Okay, I'll be off then
Yeah
there's still something -
Sneasel and mallet was that okay. It's mallet and chisel all right. I've got those good. Good good
What do I do with them? What do I do?
Hey, this guy you keep dancing this guy you have a good time this guy sinister-looking
Well this guy's a bigger schnoz and me he has a face like a half-consumed Volk Aryan, but he plays that loot like an angel
Bravo I was this going gonna be Dingle dangle Dingle Dingle dangle great ok great wonderful. I'm really happy about
What are you two doing up there? What are all of you doing up there?
Why are there two people in one hoody that doesn't make no kids? It's two people in one hoody
This guys having a great time. What are you doing blacksmith? How are you doing? Are you doing?
Colorfully dressed blackface sitting in some sort of grinding wheel all right. Oh. What was that for it's keeping you on your toes
Okay, thanks
Hello, hello. Where are you then on the blacksmith and make metal into different shapes for living alright?
How's the blacksmithing business? It's a tough time for a true artisan like me?
I'm capable of forging the finest suits of armor and the sharpest swords
But this area is enjoying a rare period of sustained peace all anyone wants around the earth
I'll flag goons and piss pots so I waste my time forging beautiful works of art that no one will buy or
Waste my talent making that for the local drunkards and only the latter option pays Oh boohoo at least you have a job
Sorry, I don't often get a chance to vent
Okay, how much metal could a blacksmith Smith if the blacksmith uh terrible you're thinking of woodchucks ok bye for now this was
Insightful, and I hate you All Right. See ya. What's in here hello? Ah?
That baby, I don't like that baby dancing, baby
How you doing from my only point of reference for this images the dancing baby, and the whimsical late 90s TV Comi?
But this is a respectable game, I only do Renaissance art Monkey Island and obscure literature references
So I have nothing to say about this baby, man. I gotta say
Every single time I walk in a new room. It is a goddamn treat. That is
just
There's just something that cannot be beat
Who it salute
Can't get to it. Can I talk to it?
Ok ah creepy lawyer. Hello, this guy looks like a real creep
Looks like the type told agree
All right, what's all this then
These lucky people just inherited a large sum of money
After the death of a relative to whom none of them had a particularly strong emotional connection
How lovely filling out the paperwork for him for a small fee of course we're gonna be flipping wrench yes
We're planning to extort the crap out of them
They have no idea just how much they've inherited these people don't know how many coppers make a silver
Nevermind the worth of the ten thousand hectares of bear barley filled with some careful manipulation of the figures
I should be able to pocket at least three quarters of their fortune, okay
Can I help you can actually I'm having trouble locating a copy of this town's official treachery deceit and extortion regulation without them
I'm only sanctioned to actually fraudulently and/or fallaciously
Which will much less profitable in this instance. Okay? If you can find me a copy. I'll give you a cut of our ill-gotten gains
Where can I get a copy of that town that?
The clerk's off its next door should be able to give you a copy, but they seem extremely reluctant to offer any help
Okay, can you give me some legal advice? What do you need to know?
I
Can a church forgive someone of sins committed out of with the church parish that's not a legal issue. I'm afraid. Okay, how about
If I murder a child in a force, but there's no one around to hear it is it still crime. Yes. Okay, how about?
Can photographic images of public domain artworks earn a new copyright? There's a more complicated issue than you might imagine okay? All right?
I'll leave you two isn't this all a bit dishonest. Yes, you have a problem with that
Yes, actually I do piss off then do-gooder okay
All right good. I'll see you around the bender
Then I don't know what the hell is happening aah
Oh, Oh
Aah, I don't know what's going on back here, but it doesn't seem good, and I don't like none of this
Okay, this guy is just pure vomiting at least it's Chellis to
piss off
Okay, how rude?
Okay, how rude is it the monkey the damn monkey?
Monkey hello some kind of security system judging by the ball and chain, I imagine he's not very happy with the arrangement okay?
All right, who's a good monkey how about I hammer and chisel your ball and chain noob that ain't happenin
This doesn't need to be chiseled or mounted okay way on way. I'm a double click this
Okay, all right, let me see if this will do it
Monkey you want some food yeah
All right doc. Hey Doc. Hey Doc
Excuse me. I'm a little busy at the moment. I have sick people to treat mmm. Okay, all right
I don't know what's going on here. I'm out here. All right
I gotta find another area some that is piss that is straight-up piss. What's this?
Hello I'm gonna take this and I'd be too distracted by this bear Willy to
Maintain eye contact during the conversation. I don't want to seem rude and or pedophile II okay all right see ya all right
What's going on over here?
Uh-huh, okay
A fisherman hi. How's it going fishing is a sacred act performed by two men who love each other very much
The delicate balance of this Mon man bonding experience should never be disturbed
My dog looks depressed oh, I don't want to get bitten can I talk to you dog Wolf Wolf ship of fools?
Some surprisingly buoyant fool singing Claudio Monteverdi steer C and Chloe
Okay, and that guy's getting bashed in the face with a pot good job. Whatever you doing Bravo
I'm very proud of you Bravo, okay, all right Bravo. I only sing instrumentals
I don't like the ones with words in because they're always trying to mean something ooh get Okita in line portrait painter
What the hell is going on underneath your skirt? I?
Don't even want to know okay, all right
What the flip bro not cool?
I'm sorry. I'm slapping a blind man. I don't know why
All right excuse me. Hello. Are you really blind best question to open with best question?
Yes, are you really a portrait painter? Yes? Will you paint my portrait of course please put two copper in the tin?
You don't have a ten
Okay, then just put them in my pocket then
I don't have to copper then you'll have to come back when you do all right
What if I already did will you pay my portrait? You don't have a ten?
I already did no you didn't I'm blind that stupid comeback
Okay, challenge the pie King for seven pence a big pile of dents meat-filled pies
Okay, keep your grubby paws of my pies. Hello pie king. How are you doing slappa slappa?
Was that supposed to hurt my grandmother slapstick hero, pot is harder than that
Okay
How about this?
Hello, puny old men. Are you ready to challenge the pie King?
What are the rules two men two pies first man-eaters pies the winner?
What's the prize?
In the extremely unlikely event that you beat the pie King you will
You win the pie king's crown in title you will become the new pie king
And you will have earned the right to ridicule and shame me in any manner you see fit all right. I'm ready
Excellent the wagers seven cents, I don't have that then you'll have to come back when you do all
righty then
What's going on here? Oh aah? Oh?
huh
All right that is weird. Don't know what to make of that but ok hello. It's probably a union issue all right
They're embroiled in a serious knife badge ugh fight. Okay, all right. I'm going up here then
Hello, oh
It's beautiful,
it's flipping beautiful God
God can you part the clouds real quick I need some advice
All Right see ya, I guess that's beautiful statue
It's a statue of a fat dwarf riding a donkey. I love it. Okay. Oh
It's the it's all the paintings used in the game oh
Oh
Oh my god. Oh, it's all the paintings used
I don't want to know where that's coming these are gonna be spoilers if I don't know where they are
Two more normal-sized man and a tiny one I wonder what they're whispering about okay?
Okay, good boy. Good boy
Good boy good boy. That's a good boy right there all right excuse me
How do you like them 'slap-ass okay, all right good job then all right
Elderly violinist a friendly old toymaker giving Johann Sebastian Bach sonata number one his best shot
Good job Bravo a painting of such beauty and complexity you can't even begin to describe it where am I going?
Why am I over here? I'm gonna go this one. Oh
Hi, hello
Okay, all right. I'm out there, so what am I supposed to do that is the question of the day this game is?
Fascinating this game is legitimately fascinating. I have no idea what to make of it
It's uh to give you a little background of it. I was perusing my recommended list on Steam and this one popped up
I like it a good bit. I like it a good bit, but I need to find a
Whole bunch of shit excuse me yes, my child. What do you want now?
Why is his church so busy people love doing sins?
But they hate feeling guilty and remorseful they also had taken responsibility for their own actions and apologizing and making genuine attempts at self-improvement
Okay, oh, and we released vast quantities of dangerous easy to burn off our cloud cover and bathe ourselves in divine looking shaft of sunlight
Yeah, that ow oh
Okay, explain to me again. We'll have to repeat all my sins. We can't take confessions
Okay, can I come and give a confession now?
You haven't committed any valid sins yet, you need to repeat all seven before we can let you in off your palm
Okey-dokey then ah here we go more more more MORE. Oh wait wait
Wait go back go back. I don't like this. Please anyway. Hello. Hi unhealthy looking drunkard. How you doing
What is it?
Then are you an oh is that your dog and as much as a man can have ownership over a beast of any nature?
No, it is not Dericks
Okay, you enjoying your ale no very much. Thanks
It's empty as a hollowed goose arse I have never heard that expression, and I never want to hear it again
You look unwell are you okay?
I got syphilis and playing in a pinch of typhus as well as everything else you might not wish for
Wisely only thing that scares off the devil is al what makes me piss like a horse with fire
Only less casual ain't got no more ale neither. So nope not, okay, I guess
Okay, all right. I should think it's about time too if I wasn't already half around the tree
I don't know what you're talking about or what that means. I do not like this place. Yeah
I don't like this piano lady looking at me like this man with pipe
talk e-excuse me sir what I sure wish I could be as happy as content as one of these couples I
Bet you do oh
I'm in this all righty then
Okay all right there we go we're good. We're good. We're good. All right. That was depressingly easy uh
Excuse me sir all right
I wish I could be dumb as uncomprehending as those children or dogs I bet you do
What I wish I could be as creepy-looking as tobacco stinky as you oh
man
Google Google
Wolf Wolf
Tim dabba doo bro. Yo buddy a good job Bravo
Okay, all right this was weird. I don't know why I went in here, but I got an achievement
So cross that bad boy off the list. I guess okay um I
Guess I guess I guess that's enough for one episode this game is so bizarre. I've never seen a game like this
I mean it's a point-and-click adventure game which are fun, but this one is just uh?
This is a flavour of something special the likes of which wait was this door hang on oh
Hi, this sort of sort of magician
Okay, all right, then well. I'm gonna walk out
I'ma walk out alright. See you guys, so I'm gonna face this up in another episode. So thank you so much for watching
Let me know what you think of this game. It's really funny. I like it
It's charming in a weird way that I haven't seen in a long time and uh
Silly I don't like that so thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know anything down in the comments below and as always I will see you in the next video. Bye